Donald Trump recently said that bigotry and
prejudice are going to leave very easily and
quickly from the United States.
Just hours after using a racial slur himself
against a sitting Democratic senator, you
probably know that Trump has a long history
of claiming that certain problems are going
to be really easy to fix.
You might remember that he said Corona virus
was just going to leave in April.
It's going to wash through and leave like
a miracle.
Obviously, that didn't happen.
He also said three and a half years ago that
his son in law, Jared Kushner, was going to
very easily and quickly fix the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict.
Obviously, that has not happened.
And here is Donald Trump speaking at a so-called
transition to greatness event, saying it himself.
Bigotry will leave quickly and easily.
Just hours after he tweeted the slur Pocahontas
about Senator Elizabeth Warren.
Here is Donald Trump himself saying it.
Americans are good and virtuous people.
We have to work together to confront bigotry
and prejudice wherever they appear.
But we'll make no progress and heal no wounds
by falsely labeling tens of millions of decent
Americans as racist or bigots.
We have to get everybody together.
We have to be in the same same path that they.
If we don't do that.
We have we have problems.
And we'll do that.
We'll do it.
I think we're going to do it very easily.
It'll go quickly and it'll go it'll go very
easily.
So.
So it's so part of the solution to bigotry
and racism from sets is to stop calling people
racist when they say racist things.
And then racism will very quickly leave our
country.
And remember, just hours before Trump said
this, he tweeted a slur about Elizabeth Warren
where he said, quote, seriously failed presidential
candidate Senator Elizabeth Pocahontas.
Warren just introduced an amendment on the
renaming of many of our legendary military
bases from which we trained to win two world
wars.
Hopefully, our great Republican senators won't
fall for this.
Also relevant to racism and bigotry is that
Donald Trump was attacking Elizabeth Warren
because she introduced an amendment looking
to rename American military bases that were
named after pro slavery Confederate generals.
Remember, the Confederacy was fighting to
preserve states rights for illegal slavery
during the American Civil War.
This is the same Donald Trump who told four
American congresswomen of color to go back
to their countries.
This is the same Trump who referred to African
countries as you know what?
Obviously, Donald Trump, as we know, is in
way over his head and himself is a heavily
bigoted individual.
But I want to put you in his shoes for a moment.
As gross as that might feel, if you don't
have any understanding of bigotry and racism,
if you don't understand the history of bigotry
and racism in the United States, as Donald
Trump doesn't understand.
If you don't understand how long bigotry and
racism have been around in the United States
and how ingrained in the country they are,
you might believe that you could really quickly
and easily fix bigotry and racism.
In reality, what's going on is that Donald
Trump completely lacks self-awareness and
is himself a huge part of the problem.
In general, when Trump is wrong about something
or makes a mistake, which he never admits
to, of course.
You can usually chalk it up to a combination
of him being what we might call a bad person
like he he lacks empathy completely.
You can chalk it up to him being ignorant.
Some would call it stupid, but that's a bit
of a pejorative ignorant.
Maybe he's better and or that he's delusional,
in other words.
He lives in a fantasy world that includes
delusions of grandeur, etc..
In this case, Trump saying bigotry will leave
quickly and easily.
It's a lack of empathy for the problems with
bigotry in our country, combined with ignorance
about the history of bigotry and racism.
The United States, with the addition of the
delusion he holds that he can fix any problem.
It's sort of like the perfect trifecta.
Now, one last thing.
I know that some of you lovely right wingers
are going to write to me or leave a comment
on YouTube or tweet me and you're gonna say,
David, Pocahontas isn't a slur was somebodies
name.
Skip it, Skip.
I'm not going to respond to you.
I'll tell you right now, Donald Trump is using
it as a slur.
Here to sarcastically refer to what in her
family was an oral history of Native American
ancestry.
This is sort of like if you sarcastically
or pejoratively refer to a Jewish person as
Schlomo when Schlomo is not their name, you
would have these same right wingers going.
David Shlomo's just short for Solomon.
It's just the name.
How is it a slur?
The context matters and the context can make
it a slur.
So please guys write right wingers put it
is mostly guys, not women.
Don't even bother writing to me about it.
Okay.
In the context Trump used it, it
was
a slur.